un club des territoires consacré à la
lutte contre les feux de forêts étaient
s'annonce à haut risque sur le front des
incendies sommes-nous près les moyens
sont-ils suffisants en débattra alors
que les députés examinent en ce moment
même un texte du Sénat pour renforcer
les mesures de prévention et pour en
parler Pascal Martin bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
sénateur centriste de la scène maritime
et rapporteur de la commission spéciale
sur la proposition de loi pour renforcer
la prévention et la lutte contre
l'intensification du risque incendie on
va bien sûr revenir là-dessus et avec
nous en duplex si elle le CRA bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous vous
êtes vice-président du syndicat national
des sapeurs-pompiers professionnels et
Antoine parat bonjour merci également
d'être avec nous vous êtes mère
d'Argelès-sur-Mer c'est dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales et justement on va
commencer avec vous Antoine parade
puisque les Pyrénées-Orientales sont
déjà touchés par les flammes votre
commune a été touchée envahir on est en
ce moment même en alerte maximale dans
votre département Gérald Darmanin
d'ailleurs annoncé hier l'envoi immédiat
de moyens supplémentaires face aux
risques incendie qu'elle est
actuellement la situation est-ce que
vous êtes inquiet
je serais extrêmement devenu de dire que
je ne suis pas inquiet ça me ferait pas
sérieusement ma part mère
d'Argelès-sur-Mer la situation est
effectivement extrêmement critique
puisque à sécheresse est profonde de
longue durée et les conditions météo ne
sont pas favorables puisque tramontant
ne souffle de manière vigoureuse toutes
les conditions sont réunies pour que un
feu d'ampleur puisse se propager
cependant j'ai confiance dans le
dispositif qui sont mises en place on
peut peut-être en parler un peu plus
longuement si vous le souhaitez mais on
va en parler mais sur l'envoi la
réaction hier de Gérald Darmanin qui a
décrété l'envoi immédiat de moyens
supplémentaires ça ça vous rassure
quelque peu ça
je sais pas s'il faut être totalement
rassuré en tous les cas on ne peut que
mettre ça va dans le bon sens
renforcer le dispositif c'est une très
très bonne chose parce que tout l'enjeu
lors de ces départs de feu qui peuvent
venir des incendies dévastateurs tout
l'enjeu et d'intervenir très rapidement
si on arrive à se présenter sur les
lieux avec des moyens
rapides et d'intervention urgente on
peut on peut combattre l'incendie à la
base à la source et ensuite c'est
incendie peut ne pas se propager
l'intervention rapide est absolument
déterminante on voit ce qui se passe
dans les Pyrénées-Orientales parce
qu'elle Martin et on est qu'au mois de
mai c'est-à-dire que la saison normale
des incendies n'est pas censé avoir
commencé est-ce qu'il faut se préparer à
un été catastrophique sur le plan des
incendies alors l'un des constats nous
avons fait à l'occasion de la mission de
l'année dernière qui prenait en compte
les feux notamment de Gironde de
Landiras de La Teste-de-Buch c'est de
dire que aujourd'hui qu'on tenus du
réchauffement climatique nous avons deux
phénomènes incontestables celui de d'une
extension géographique du risque
d'incendie c'est à dire que ça ne touche
plus uniquement le bassin méditerranéen
mais aucun département était épargné
potentiellement par ce risque et puis
c'est l'extension également temporelle
puisque la saison des feux de forêt qui
il y a encore quelques années ne
concernait que les mois d'été
aujourd'hui démarre très tôt on le voit
ici même à Argelès au mois de mai mais
il y a eu déjà des feux fin février
début mars et jusque à l'automne donc
une saison 2023 compte tenu des
conditions de sécheresse des vents avec
un trop un taux d'humidité très faible
le cocktail est réuni pour que nous
vivions une nouvelle saison
catastrophique des feux de forêt il y a
le crash je vais demander ce que vous en
pensez je me rappelle vous êtes
vice-président du syndicat national des
sapeurs-pompiers professionnels le
cocktail est réuni vous êtes d'accord
pour qu'on ait un été catastrophique sur
le plan des incendies
alors je suis d'accord sur le fait que
le cocktail est effectivement réuni le
stress hydrique à sécheresse on a toutes
les conditions pour que des feux
d'ampleur puisse redémarrer est-ce que
l'été sera catastrophique je ne peux pas
le dire évidemment à l'avance nous le
craignons tous des moyens sont engagés
de notre point de vue une anticipation
plus importante aurait pu être
envisagé
on réclame depuis de nombreuses années
le prépositionnement de certains moyens
notamment de lutte aérienne dans le
Sud-Ouest ou ailleurs que dans la zone
habituellement concernée qui est dans le
sud-est ses moyens ont tardé et on sait
que notamment les avions sont importants
au départ des feux pour pouvoir les
taper vite et forts et limiter leur
ampleur c'est vraiment un question
essentielle sur le prépositionnement sur
la question des moyens que vous
envisagez que vous abordez avec ce que
Monsieur Darmanin a indiqué évidemment
ils sont les bienvenus et les élus
locaux les populations les verront
arrivé avec avec satisfaction néanmoins
l'intérêt de ces renforts est limités
par le fait qu'ils sont peu nombreux
malgré tout parce que les viviers sont
les mêmes on prélève des moyens d'un
côté pour les envoyer de l'autre donc ce
sont les départements les moins touchés
qui concourent par la solidarité
nationale et le mécanisme de sécurité
civile qui concourent à renforcer les
départements en difficulté mais ces
moyens sont limités sont les mêmes
personnes qui sont sollicitées et cette
ressource n'est pas inépuisable juste
pour qu'on soit bien clair il y a le
crabe pardon vous parlez des moyens
envoyés hier dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales où vous parlez des
annonces faites il y a quelques jours
pour Gérald Darmanin pour l'été à venir
qui sont pas suffisants les deux puisque
les moyens sont sont
la ressource dont on dispose et la même
que ce soit les moyens aériens envoyés
ou les moyens humains les colonnes de
renfort ou les colonnes de renfort que
l'on envoie lorsque le feu s'est déclaré
c'est le même vivier on prélève sur des
ressources existantes pour les
redistribuer ailleurs ne sont pas
réellement des moyens supplémentaires
mais c'est une redistribution des moyens
existants et la vraie question qu'il
faut se poser c'est quel niveau de
d'investissement en termes on est prêt à
mettre sur la table pour lutter contre
les feux de forêts en sachant que
Monsieur sénateur a parfaitement bien
dit que on est à la fois dans le temps
de la réaction mais que notre temps
c'est le temps long on est dans le
réchauffement climatique et on parle des
feux de forêt mais vous pourriez me
poser exactement la même question
concernant les inondations ou les
tempêtes ou d'autres catastrophes
naturelles qui sont induites par le
réchauffement climatique
et Alex juste pour qu'on soit bien clair
sur ce que dit le crack quelles sont les
moyens précisément qui ont été annoncés
par Gérard Darmanin il y a quelques
semaines pour cet été il y aura 9 avions
hélicoptères bombardiers d'eau
supplémentaires portant à la flotte de
Bombardier de 38 à 47 engins 500
sapeurs-pompiers supplémentaires seront
aussi mobilisés pour cet été et puis
dans les prochaines années la flotte de
Canada sera intégralement renouvelée
avec quatre avions supplémentaires ce
qui fera 16 Canadair au total c'est pas
suffisant pour vous parce qu'elle Martin
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
la réponse opérationnelle la doctrine de
la sécurité civile jusqu'à il y a encore
quelques années répondait efficacement
au problème de la lutte contre les feux
d'incendie et sur avec une technique de
matraquage des feux naissants et
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que depuis
deux années au moins
les feux à 95% des feux de forêt des
feux de végétation ne dépassent pas les
5 hectares brûlés c'est les 5 hectares
les 5% restants qui posent problème et
donc il faut absolument travailler à la
prévention du risque incendie d'une part
et d'autre part à la réponse
opérationnelle et donc les moyens
supplémentaires sont les bienvenus mais
je considère qu'il faudra aller plus
loin en termes de moyens aérien qui sont
supportés par la solidarité nationale et
par le budget de l'État et par les
moyens qui sont consacrés par les
services départementaux d'incendie et de
secours qui font déjà beaucoup d'efforts
financés par les Conseils départementaux
et par les communes pour former les
personnels pour acquérir de nouveaux
matériels donc c'est à c'est vraiment la
solidarité nationale qui doit jouer pour
faire face à ce risque essentiel qui est
celui de l'incendie
et mon comment se prépare les pompiers à
cet été particulier Audrey Vittaz nous
emmène dans les Bouches-du-Rhône au cœur
de la préparation des pompiers qui vous
allez le voir sont aidés de nouveaux
outils
en quelques secondes ses pompiers se
retrouvent cernés par les flammes les
conducteurs des camions doivent
déclencher de toute urgence leur
auto-protection ce jour-là il ne s'agit
que d'un exercice une formation initiale
sur cette aire unique en Europe les
flammes ont été créées par du gaz les
arbres sont en métal l'objectif c'est
d'être prêt pour un été qui pourrait
être très compliqué et au travers de cet
outil là on va les exposer notamment à
la réalité du rayonnement à l'importance
des flammes que l'on va retrouver sur
les feux d'espace naturel et en
particulier feux de forêt bien
évidemment la période qui s'ouvre avec
l'état de sécheresse nous préoccupe nous
interroge renforce notre préparation et
on est particulièrement déjà mobilisé au
sol et dans les airs avec des drones
comme celui-ci hyper sophistiqués
pour ce drone il a comme particularité
donc une caméra thermique qui est assez
puissante un zoom on a ici un télémètre
laser qui va nous permettre de pointer
des points GPS donc on va s'en servir
sur les recherches de points chauds
l'été les images qu'ils filment sont
retransmises en temps réel sur l'écran
de ce camion ici on repère les flamants
rouges grâce à une caméra thermique on a
les températures qui s'affichent à
mesure le 160 degrés à mesure en fin de
feu quand on doit faire le noyage des
lisières on se sert de ça pour voir
uniquement les points chauds ce qui
évite de de relier toute la lisière sur
des grands feux c'est important parce
que on perdrait du temps à noyer des
endroits qui sont froids alors que là
avec ce système là on peut arriver à
cibler les endroits pour le noyade pour
battre le feu il faut aussi l'anticiper
la forêt elle est prête à brûler car je
t'y prête à brûler c'est qu'elle a un
taux d'hygrométrie qui est très très bas
puis évidemment il y a des jours où il y
a du Mistral et ça c'est les conditions
extrêmes ou dans à ces jours là et bien
nous faisons un système de prévention
pour être au plus tôt sur le départ de
feu quand il a lieu c'est ici que la
start-up HD règne entre en jeu avec un
millier de capteurs comme celui-ci
déployé sur tout l'arc méditerranéen
dans les massifs sur les casernes là où
Météo France ne va pas là on voit des
cartes de température
donc en fait l'idée quand les pompiers
regardent cette carte c'est d'aller
zoomer à 500 mètres près pour aller voir
les différences de température donc là
clairement on peut voir des différences
qui sont assez significatives d'une zone
à une autre et en couplant ces
informations là avec des informations
d'humidité par exemple les pompiers sont
en capacité d'aller à délimiter les
zones qui sont plus à risque les
pompiers en fait utilisent la règle de
30 ça veut dire
voilà il faut qu'il y ait quand on
regarde l'humidité quand on dépasse 30%
30 degrés de température et 30 km de
vent en fonction des territoires et bah
ça veut dire que le risque est plus
important ou moins important avec
l'espoir d'être un jour capable de
prévoir les incendies avant qu'il ne se
déclenche
avant parler de cet espoir et justement
de la prévention on va y venir vous avez
vu il y a des nouvelles technologies qui
aident beaucoup les pompiers à lutter
contre ces feux de forêts Pascal Martin
oui non mais c'est incontestable étant
ancien colonel de sapeur-pompiers
professionnels je mesure l'évolution des
techniques et de la formation des
personnels je crois que il faut un se
préparer dans la prévision du risque
incendie mais il faut aussi travailler à
la prévention
90% des incendies sont d'origine
anthropique d'origine humaine et donc
nous avons dans notre proposition de loi
qui est aujourd'hui débattue à
l'Assemblée nationale décidé de
travailler sur ces comportements humains
pour faire en sorte de réduire au
maximum ce risque incendie mais il est
incontestable et je le salue les progrès
dématériels et des techniques d'attaque
sont incontestables indéniables ce sont
des efforts conséquents portés par les
services départementaux d'incendie de
secours et on le voit
un pied pour aider à lutter contre ces
incendies et
Jes qu'un jour on pourra anticiper un
incendie avant même qu'il ne se
déclenche
écoutez il y a différentes phases
effectivement la prévention la prévision
la prévision je pense que l'implication
du citoyen est importante
néanmoins j'ai envie de dire la forêt
brûle mais soyons tranquille nous avons
une application c'est pas suffisant
évidemment que ça va dans le bon sens
évidemment que ça aide le travail et que
ça permet une meilleure réactivité moi
ce que ce que ce qui me vient en tête
quand je vois ce reportage c'est que
malgré tout il faudra à la fin de la fin
des moyens matériels et humains pour
aller éteindre ces incendies et
lorsqu'ils se seront déclarés et on a de
la technologie qui évidemment
utile mais il faudra aussi de la masse
du volume en moyenne j'allais dire de
base pour aller éteindre ces incendies
je rappelle que en Gironde on a toujours
30% du matériel incendie suite à
l'endiras et ce qui s'est passé cet été
qui hors service donc des drones qui
font des images et qui qui aident le
travail de tous évidemment il faut le
saluer mais il faut en parallèle être
capable comme pour la chose militaire de
tenir des des fronts de haute intensité
pendant longtemps et là c'est des moyens
beaucoup plus basiques qu'il faut et ça
revient la question de ce que la société
est prête à mettre sur la table en
termes d'investissement quel niveau de
sécurité on souhaite avoir et qu'elle
acceptabilité du risque on est prêt
collectivement à supporter on pourra pas
tout le temps tout éteindre sans parler
de la question du coup du financement et
de l'acceptation sociale de cette lutte
contre les incendie concrètement
pour cet été est-ce que vous arrivez à
chiffrer combien il faudrait de Canadair
en plus combien il faudrait de dash en
plus combien il faudrait d'hommes en
plus de camions en plus alors ça dépend
évidemment de ce que l'on aura à
défendre comme territoire sur la
question des avions
l'Europe a proposé un financement d'une
flotte d'avion qui était à la
disposition si je peux simplifier comme
ça des pays membres et participants aux
mécanisme européen de protection civile
la France attardée à lever la main pour
dire nous avons besoin de ces avions le
résultat c'est que effectivement il y a
des moyens aériens qui vont arriver et
qui seront supportés non pas par
l'Europe qu'il les financé
quasiment intégralement pour certains
mais ça va être supporté par le budget
national c'est typiquement une ressource
sur laquelle on nous aurions pu nous
appuyer et le ministère de l'Intérieur
la DGS CGC n'a pas suivi
cette n'a pas saisi cette opportunité
donc combien ce qu'il faut de moyens on
peut pas être dans le toujours plus
sinon on dirait que qu'ils ont le
chiffre serait intenable pour la société
néanmoins il faut renforcer ses moyens
et sur la question des hommes je suis
j'insiste le vivier et le même notre
volontariat s'épuise le nom de
professionnels n'est pas un augmentation
et il faudra à la fin de la fin jour des
sapeurs-pompiers pour aller éteindre ses
feux et cette question elle reste sur la
table
je rappelle vous êtes mère
d'Argelès-sur-Mer votre commune a été
touchée est-ce qu'il y a aussi une
préparation qui doit être faite auprès
des élus locaux vous comment vous avez
géré quand votre commune a été touchée
par un incendie est-ce que vous étiez
prêt suffisamment formé est-ce que vous
avez su comment réagir
oui écoutez lorsque
sur mer évidemment il a des
professionnels 10 et là près parce que
les conditions se prête à ce que tout le
monde soit en alerte le maire ne fait
que essayer de faire la gravation entre
la gendarmerie la police municipale et
les pompiers et les pompiers sont là
pour intervenir moi ce que je voudrais
apporter quand même une note d'optimisme
un petit peu si c'est possible dans ce
dans ce dossier c'est que les conditions
extrêmes d'incendie possible ce ne sont
pas des conditions inédites nous les
connaissons régulièrement au mois de
juillet et août dans notre région ce qui
inédit c'est la saison au printemps ça
ne s'était jamais produit et je veux
dire que le meilleur incendie et
l'incendie qui ne se déclare pas ou bien
celui qui est pris à la source et c'est
là aussi qu'il faut travailler
énormément parce que je suis absolument
d'accord avec
le Corona de justice qui est intervenu
c'est vrai que une fois que l'incendie
déclaré il faut énormément de moyens
pour essayer de contenir c'est très
difficile il faut des hommes et des
moyens c'est certain mais nous ici sur
notre territoire depuis 5 ans nous avons
créé une risque une réserve
intercommunale de sécurité civile qui
est composé d'une centaine de
volontaires bénévole qui parcourient
massive avec des moyens qu'on leur a
louons et ils peuvent intervenir
rapidement sur tous les paris incendie
et surtout également ils font œuvre de
pédagogie par rapport à tous les
randonneurs qui peut y avoir dans la
Macif et qui peut-être commettrait des
imprudences et bien le fait qu'ils
soient interpellés par ces personnes ils
attention les conditions sont difficiles
il faut être très prudent rien que ce
genre d'intervention ça permet d'éviter
un incendie qui aurait pu se déclarer
par un prudence parce que nous savons
tous que le maximum d'incendie sont
d'origine humaine la très large majorité
sont d'origine humaine pas toujours
malveillante mais quand même et donc
cette prévention à la base nous a évité
depuis cinq ans alors que nous
connaissons encore une fois au mois de
juillet et août les mêmes conditions
qu'on ne connaissons aujourd'hui et bien
depuis 5 ans il n'y a pas eu le moindre
départ d'incendie dans notre massif je
crois que c'est lui un peu aussi à la
prévention en amont ça vient aider nos
sapeurs-pompiers qui c'est vrai que
lorsque l'incendie déclaré on a
absolument besoin d'eux et de tous les
moyens dont ils ont besoin aussi pour
pour combattre un incendie qui ensuite
est très difficilement maîtrisable donc
important et je crois que nous y
arrivons depuis quelques années
l'important est d'essayer de
d'intervenir en amont d'envoyer des
sentinelles sur le terrain pour que bien
ça dit justement ne se déclare pas et
c'est tout l'objet de votre aveaux parce
qu'elle Martin sur la prévention le
texte qui a été voté à l'unanimité au
Sénat est actuellement débat à
l'Assemblée avant de vous entendre on va
voir ce que contient ce texte avec Alex
effectivement Oriane c'est une
proposition de loi initié par la
majorité de droite et du centre du Sénat
elle vise d'abord à créer une stratégie
nationale de lutte contre les incendies
de forêt et de préservation de nos
forêts en coordonnant les différents
acteurs et puis l'objectif c'est de
renforcer la prévention de ces feux on
va écouter la ministre de la cohésion
des territoires Dominique fort qui
soutenaient ce texte hier à l'Assemblée
nationale
va falloir agir plus sur l'origine des
feux lorsqu'on sait que 90% des départs
de feux de forêt sont liés à une
activité humaine notre priorité d'agir
sur les interfaces entre forêt et
habitations soyons clairs les
obligations légales de débroussaillement
fixés dans le Code forestier doit être
mieux mis en œuvre alors qu'on estime
qu'elles le sont seulement à 30%.
pourtant leur efficacité n'est plus à
démontrer et bien justement cette
proposition de loi renforce l'obligation
légale de débroussaillement pour les
propriétaires des terrains proches des
forêts les sanctions pénales en cas de
non-respect de cette obligation ont été
accrues par les sénateurs puis parler
députés en commission cela peut aller
jusqu'à 10 ans de prison et 150000 euros
d'amende la vente d'un terrain est
conditionnée au respect de cette
obligation de débroussaillement et puis
les drones permettront aux collectivités
locales de contrôler cette obligation
cela a été ajouté par les députés un
texte qui prévoit d'autres mesures de
prévention et consacre l'interdiction de
fumer dans les forêts les plus exposées
au risque de feu et jusqu'à 200 mètres
dans les zones aux alentours et le gène
négo sera d'ailleurs une cause
d'incendie volontaires sanctionnable
pénalement et puis en cas de fort
incendie le préfet pourra aussi
interdire certains travaux agricoles
avec une indemnisation des agriculteurs
dans ces cas-là et puis les coupes
d'arbres tactiques vont être intégrés
dans le Code forestier les coupes
d'arbres tactiques se sont des coupes
rases de certaines parcelles pour créer
des zones pare-feu et c'est une
technique qui a été utilisée elle était
dernier la prévention c'est la clé parce
qu'elle Martin dans la lutte encore une
fois je partage qui a été dit par
Monsieur le Maire et puis par mon ex
collègue ça pour pompier effectivement
il faut travailler à la prévention sans
négliger la réponse opérationnelle les
obligations légales de débroussaillement
que vous venez d'évoquer sont une
réponse pertinente malheureusement
aujourd'hui pour diverses raisons 30%
sont exécutés alors que dans les faits
dans les faits alors ça coûte un peu
d'argent
il y a sûrement un manque d'information
il y a peut-être à renforcer la
la pédagogie sur l'utilité de ces
obligations légales de débroussaillement
un elle protège lorsqu'elles sont bien
faites l'habitation de elles peuvent
permettre sous certaines conditions à ce
que les personnes puissent rester dans
leur habitation pendant pendant un feu
et puis trois ça permet de dégager des
moyens qui sont bloqués auprès
d'habitation pour les engager sur
d'autres d'autres théâtres d'opérations
et donc ces obligations légales de
débroussaillement nous souhaitons
véritablement qu'elle soit multipliée
reste la problématique du contrôle qui
est exercée par les maires des communes
Monsieur le Maire pourra nous en parler
je pense et à défaut par le préfet mais
encore une fois nous avons mis si vous
me permettez l'expression le paquet sur
ces old vous les avez parlé de de
mutation vous avez parlé de franchise
d'assurance qui devront prendre en
compte ces obligations légales de
débroussaillement c'est vraiment une
sensibilisation plus forte que nous
souhaitons apporter aux propriétaires de
terrain on va faire répondre à Antoine
parat à la fois sur la la
sensibilisation des citoyens est-ce
qu'ils sont suffisamment informés est-ce
qu'ils sont suffisamment conscients du
risque lorsqu'ils ne respectent pas le
débroussaillement et de comment vous
pouvez contrôler pour que le
débroussaillement est bien réalisé
oui site nous sensibilisons toute la
population sur l'importance du
débroussaillement d'ailleurs je rappelle
que le récent incendique qui a eu un âge
sur mer il y a 15 jours a pu être
contenu un certain moment parce que il
est arrivé sur une zone qui avait été
très correctement débroussaillée ça a
permis de maîtriser davantage qui ne
franchissent pas la ligne de crête ce
qui aurait pu être catastrophique tout
le massif on peut plus être pris à ce
moment-là et c'est vraiment cette zone
de qui a été bien débroussaillée qui a
permis que me fera gentil c'est qu'il
puisse être maîtrisé l'année dernière et
gagner d'avant plusieurs personnes ont
été verbalisées donc nous travaillons
nos insistons beaucoup pour que
débroussaillement soit fait correctement
mais je puisque il y a sur le plateau
monsieur sénateur qui travaille sur ces
questionnaires incendies je voudrais
suggérer quand même une une proposition
sur feu de Cerbère il y a trois semaines
qui a dévasté qui est le plus grand ou
plus important qu'il y a diversité 900
hectares il y a 3 semaines et bien la
question se pose du débroussaillement
obligatoire près de lotissement qui
proche de zones auparavant travailler en
agriculture par des vignes qui ont été
abandonnées qui sont devenus des friches
et aujourd'hui ont l'obligation de
débroussaillement les maisons du
lotissement qui sont qui sont en lisière
de de
la friche mais pas une maison qui sont
derrière donc tous les frais doivent
être engagés par les personnes qui sont
en Isère de l'affiche alors qu'elle
protégeront tout lotissement ce qui fait
que certaines personnes n'ont pas les
moyens parce que ce sont des personnes
âgées qu'elles ont des faibles revenus
elles n'ont pas les moyens de
débroussailler et et les maisons qui
sont derrière dans elles n'ont aucune
obligation donc il y a peut-être un
partage de l'investissement à prendre en
compte parce que le débroussaillement ne
protège pas simplement la première
maison mais protège tout le lotissement
nous avons fait la loi fait quelque
chose de semblable au niveau de la
gymapie la production contre les
inondations ou une taxe et prélevée sur
l'ensemble de la population je crois
qu'il faudrait réfléchir un peu au
partage de l'investissement parce que le
débroussaillement d'une parcelle ne
protège pas que la maison ou
l'habitation concernée mais toute une
partie de la population donc peut-être
prendre en compte cette dimension mais
effectivement je confirme que de
débroussaillement est une réponse
adaptée à ce que les feux ne prennent
pas les ampoules trop importantes oui
alors nous avons prévu en partie une
réponse à votre interrogation légitime
qui se rencontrent régulièrement sur le
terrain puisque un crédit d'impôt a été
voté égal à 50% des dépenses
effectivement supportées et retenu dans
la limite de 2000 euros par foyer fiscal
alors c'est quand même pas neutre sous
réserve de l'adoption définitive de la
proposition loi mais donc c'est une des
réponses parce que l'investissement le
premier investissement pour réaliser un
débroussaillement et plus conséquent
ensuite c'est de l'entretien annuel qui
coûte moins cher mais encore une fois
nous avons prévu un crédit d'impôt à
hauteur de 2000 euros mais alors ça
c'est pour ceux qui supportent le
débroussaillement mais ce que dit le
maire sur dans un lotissement il y a
ceux qui sont en Isère et qui doivent
débroussailler et puis il y a les autres
bénéficie du débroussaillement de ceux
qui sont en lisière est-ce que là il
faut réfléchir à un meilleur partage
alors nous avons également prévu
d'intégrer dans les PLU dans les plans
local d'urbanisme les zones où le
débroussaillement doit être effectué
donc nous y travaillons encore mais nous
l'avons noté dans divers auditions il y
a des cas rencontrés sur le terrain qui
peuvent poser problème mais globalement
et d'une façon assez générale nous
pensons que les Old sont véritablement
un outil pertinent avec le travail et je
profite de l'occasion pour saluer le
travail des agriculteurs qui nous
accompagnent également des sylviculteurs
aussi et donc c'est un travail partagé
pour améliorer cet outil efficace
elle part donc peut-être pour finir un
dernier tour de table vous disiez que et
pendant longtemps le risque d'incendie
il a été concentré dans le sud-est puis
là le Sud-Ouest est-ce qu'aujourd'hui le
risque d'incenti d'incendie il est
présent partout sur le territoire et ce
qui rend les choses peut-être encore
plus difficile à gérer en termes de
moyens
oui à l'évidence les ce qu'on a ce qu'on
a à faire face effectivement des feux de
grande ampleur sur le plan géographique
ça remonte vers le nord on a vu les feux
en Bretagne on a vu des feux qui
remontaient vraiment très très au nord
je rappelle que il y a quelques années
il y a une énorme feu en Suède au
printemps des faits de très très grande
ampleur donc le phénomène remonte moi la
vertu que je vois malgré tout si on veut
être positif à ces incendies qui ont
marqué les esprits c'est que ils ont
fait rentrer la question du risque dans
le débat politique et on le voit il y a
des propositions de loi il y a des
initiatives locales il y a une question
qui émerge et qui place au cœur de la
société se débat sur notre notre
sécurité sur les moyens que l'on doit y
mettre sur la part que chacun doit
prendre le citoyen on parle du
débroussaillement
les maires qui sont les directeurs des
opérations sur lesquels une importante
partie des responsabilités revient
malgré tout notamment dans la attention
enfin toute la chaîne des secours et est
apparu au grand jour je dirais dans la
société et on en débat donc oui il faut
se préparer à des incendies de plus
grande ampleur qui remontent au nord il
faut se préparer à la question de la
gestion de l'eau sur la vision de des
inondations vraiment le phénomène c'est
un phénomène de temps long donc qu'il y
ait des mesures à court terme pour
lutter contre l'incendies des mesures
optimisation c'est une très bonne chose
et nous nous le saluons mais il faut que
l'on pose la question de notre système
de secours notamment sur la question du
financement sur le long terme parce que
on n'est pas sur une ou deux années il
faut vraiment qu'on anticipe qu'est-ce
que l'on veut comme niveau de sécurité
pour la France en termes de protection
civile d'ici 10 15 20 ans et ça c'est un
débat politique et nous devons le mener
ensemble et on va conclure ce débat avec
vous parce qu'elle Martin pour vous
répondiez aux interrogations et à
l'alerte finalement lancé parielle Kra
oui alors c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le
risque concerne l'ensemble du territoire
métropolitain on l'a vu dans le Morbihan
l'année dernière dans les Vosges et donc
la vraie difficulté c'est que la
doctrine opérationnelle aujourd'hui
repose sur la solidarité
interdépartementale de colonnes de
renfort qui viennent soit en préventif
soit en curatif à portée
leur appui au département jusqu'à lors
sudiste et ça sera difficile dans les
années à venir puisque encore une fois
on ne pourra pas déshabiller Paul pour
habiller Jacques donc il va falloir
repenser la doctrine opérationnelle de
la sécurité civile repensez également je
partage le financement des services
départementaux d'incendie de secours ne
doit-on pas faire jouer la solidarité
nationale sur un risque qui est
aujourd'hui à l'échelle nationale c'est
toutes ces questions que cette
proposition de loi pose sans y apporter
toutes les réponses mais nous sommes
prêts à aller plus loin dans cette
réflexion merci elle le crâne d'avoir
été avec nous vice-président du syndicat
national des sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels et merci beaucoup
également Antoine parrain mère
d'Argelès-sur-Mer dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales d'avoir été avec
nous pour ce débat parce qu'elle Martin
vous restez parce que Alex va nous dire
ce qu'elle a une de nos quotidiens
régionaux
[Musique]
et Alex Emmanuel Macron il a pas
passionné la presse régionale un peu de
journaux reviennent sur son intervention
d'hier n'oublie pas vraiment un seul
montre que le Président de la République
n'a pas fait beaucoup d'annonces
nouvelles hier soir c'était surtout une
opération de pédagogie La Dépêche du
Midi revient quand même aujourd'hui sur
un engagement du Président de la
République prière soir une baisse
d'impôts de 2 milliards d'euros pour les
classes moyennes d'ici à la fin du
quinquennat alors qui sont les classes
moyennes pour Emmanuel Macron et bien je
le cite ce sont les Françaises et
Français qui travaillent dur qui veulent
bien élever leur enfant et qui
aujourd'hui parce que le coût de la vie
à monter ont du mal à boucler à la fin
du mois Emmanuel Macron qui avait
précisé et situé ses classes moyennes
dans des salaires entre 1500 euros et
2500 euros c'était hier dans son
interview dans le journal l'opinion et
puis dans l'édition toulousaine La
Dépêche du Midi fait sa Une sur cette
retraité de 70 ans qui hier à Florence a
pris en otage sa femme de ménage la
femme de ménage était l'employée de son
bailleur et la personne retraitée par ce
geste a voulu dénoncer les conditions
indignes de son
avec par exemple un dégât des eaux qui
n'est pas traité depuis 9 mois la
personne retraitée s'est rendue
finalement au gendarmes après plusieurs
heures de négociation et la crise du
logement s'étaline de Var-Matin
s'intéresse à la crise du logement
social dans le département du Var la
demande de logements social n'a jamais
été aussi élevée elle a augmenté cette
année de 10% plus 7% au niveau national
et pour avoir un logement social dans le
département du Var en moyenne il faut
attendre deux ans c'est une situation
qui est traduit et bien une crise
générale du secteur du logement dans
notre pays les ménages n'achètent plus
de bien immobilier à cause de
l'inflation les bailleurs renoncent
aussi à louer certains biens avec de
nouvelles normes environnementales et
énergétiques qui sont contraignantes et
puis il y a une pénurie actuellement de
logements neufs le tapis rouge est
déroulé le Festival de Cannes des buts
ce soir mais oui c'est la 76ème édition
de du festival de cinéma qui commence ce
soir avec la projection du film de
Maïwenn gène du Barry dans lequel elle
incarne la dernière favorite du un Louis
XV ce qui est joué par Johnny Depp d'où
ce titre pour le journal Sud-Ouest
Cannes le cinéma roi le journal La
Provence fait aussi ça une sur le
Festival de Cannes et souligne le
casting en or de cette édition avec une
pléiade de stars au programme notamment
des stars américaines Leonardo DiCaprio
et Robert De Niro qui vont présenter le
dernier film de Martin score 16 et puis
Harrison Ford qui va défendre le
cinquième volet des aventures
d'Indiana Jones
de la marseillaise qui a dit qu'il y
aura aussi d'autres acteurs dans cette
édition dans cette édition du Festival
de Cannes et bien des manifestants
contre la réforme des retraites puisque
à la CGT compte bien jouer aussi un rôle
dans cet événement pour faire une caisse
de résonance dans sa mobilisation un
tapis rouge de colère titre La
Marseillaise merci beaucoup Alex pour
cette revue de presse merci Pascal
Martin d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
débat on vous retrouve évidemment vite
dans cette émission merci à tous de nous
avoir suivis pour la voir ou la revoir
notre site public sénat.fr à 18h vous
avez rendez-vous avec Thomas Hugues et
nous on se retrouve demain très bonne
journée
[Musique]